ah oui balayé ewald comme tout bon
moment des faits l'avaient squeeze
épisode serge tu parle anglais alors
premièrement j'aimerais vous donner une
explication quant aux rouleaux de pq que
je vous ai montré dans ma dernière vidéo
1 que je peux voir en cliquant juste là
je vous laisse une seconde cordialement
alors beaucoup d'entre eux vont ont cru
que j'étais un gros pervers qui se
masturbait devant mon écran attendait
mais les gars mais c'est quoi ça tout
gamer se doit d'avoir du pq sur son
bureau mais pas pour ce que vous pensez
pour tout à fait autre chose bon voici
l'explication en images
[Musique]
la technique du gros rageur et encore
j'ai pas dernières technologies certains
gamers vont encore plus loin que le pq
[ __ ]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs je pense que cette petite
enceinte pourraient faire l'objet d'une
pub de la part de l'entreprise boules
quiès turin la main de ce genre le mec
sur la droite
oui oui j'en ai marre tu veux les
solutions oubli tu es sûr oui vraiment
et merde t'as pas une solution wadja tu
me parles lui au pnud un connard
boules quiès tu l'aimés et autant plus
rien en belgique mais j'ai tout de même
trouvé une fonction très utile avec
cette petite enceinte portative à savoir
cacher ces bruits lorsqu'on va aux
toilettes alors avant j'utilisais une
boîte à meuh
j'utilise désormais ce petit truc alors
autant dire que parfois les gens ont des
doutes 1 cc suspect quand même c'est à
dire qu'on s'attend plutôt à ça on ouvre
la porte des toilettes
[Musique]
sauf qu'en fait derrière la porte ya ça
tu es coupable pour cacher qu'il soit
tu veux voir ma [ __ ]
bref le bac s'est terminée aujourd'hui
je vous parlais de quelques trucs qui
m'ont marqué durant ces foutus épreuve
alors déjà c'est le seul jour de l'année
où tu prends autant soin de remplir
correctement ta trousse un c'est vrai
que le reste de l'année généralement on
a toujours des résidus de gommer des
cadaves de crayon de papier dans notre
trousse est bien là non si le bleu le
blanc et le bleu bon je pense que ça
fera d'affaires 1 j'aurais de quoi
écrire demain j'aurai carte de la sur
terre
comme sur l'eau - je manquerai pas
et alors le moment le plus terrible de
ces fameuses épreuves c'est lorsque tu
as le sziget devant toi et que en
l'ouvrant tu pries pour tomber sur telle
ou telle chose et surtout ne pas tomber
sur un talus belles choses a dès lors il
ya toujours 2 3 go go dans la salle qui
lorsqu'il voit qu'ils sont tombés sur le
sujet sur lequel il voulait tomber une
réaction un peu un peu chiante quoi
c'est énervant c'est chiant a été ok
[Musique]
est tout à l'opposé tu retrouves
certains candidats qui eux sont vraiment
en dépression totale en découvrant un
sujet qu'ils n'ont pas révisé il ya même
des catastrophes qui peuvent arriver un
sas et on on sait pas 1
[Musique]
si bon petit moment pour ma part quand
j'ai découvert le sujet de philo j'ai
une réaction proche de celle ci
bonjour waka
[Musique]
par contre autant vous dire qu'en
découvrant le sujet de maths et j'ai
presque réagi comme ça la foulée
[Musique]
la vidéo what the fuck du jour c'est
quelqu'un qui a je pense sacrément
enragé sur fifa et c'est quelqu'un qu'on
virage il insulte pas il fut pas le
juste comme ça hippie sur son jeu tout
va bien
[Applaudissements]
je voulais juste imaginer ainsi sept
personnes quand elles rage dans la vraie
vie contre ses amis ou d'autres trucs
réagi de la même manière on obtient des
trucs plutôt plutôt louche quand même
me tiens regarde la super nouvelle part
au chocolat que j'ai acheté avec du
caramel naples et de pépites de chocolat
theurillat s'était déjà dit que j'étais
allergique sur voila
mais tu paies ce brevet
c'était un gros débit